au président Hervé Marseille pour le
groupe de l'Union
centrist monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues à mon tour
au nom de mon groupe je voudrais
m'associer au président l'archer dans
ses propos vis-à-vis d'Israël et nous
tenons bien sûr au côté d'Israël dans
cette épreuve notre continent notre
vieux continent depuis des siècles connu
bien des guerres des massacres des
porommes des charniers des horreurs de
toutes sortes nous pensions avoir
atteint le bout de ces horreurs dans ce
que nous avons entendu et vu et puis
finalement un degré supplémentaire a été
perpétré en Israël le 7 octobre avec
l'incursion des tueurs du Hamas des
hommes des femmes des vieillards des
bébés
décapités on navait jamais vu ça c'est
un abilissement cela a été dit par le
président canner de la civilisation
l'humanité c'est insupportable on ne
trouve plus les mots j'ai cherché
moi-même les mots je pouvais employer on
ne trouve plus les mots c'est tueur
parce que certains voudraient nous faire
croire qu'il s'agit de résistants on n
jamais vu des résistants qui tuaient des
enfants des jeunes des jeunes hommes et
des jeunes femmes dans une rêveptie ou
qui décapiter des bébés on n'a jamais vu
ça ce sont des tueurs tout simplement et
ces tueurs ils s nulle part ils ont été
accompagnés ils ont été aidés entraînés
financés et on sait par qui on sait par
qui par le Qatar puisque le chef des
tueurs estébergé au Qatar monsieur anier
est au Qatar ca même qui finance ici le
PSG ou d'autres grandes
entreprises et
puis et puis il y a
l'Iran et nous avons été très
conciliants vis-à-vis de l'Iran dans le
dossier nucléaire en particulier pour
rechercher des solutions parce que nous
pensions que c'était important pour la
paix dans le monde et pour la région
alors madame la Première ministre ma
question est simple quel conséquences le
gouvernement tire-t-il de l'implication
de ces deux pays dans les relations avec
ces pays et quelles actions
entendons-nous prendre en France pour
mettre un terme à leur implication dans
ces meurtres barbares je vous rem
[Applaudissements]
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le président Hervé
Marseille l'attaque terroriste commise
par le Hamas contre Israël est odieuse
vous l'avez dit
inqualifiable un groupe terroriste sonen
est pris à des civils dans un déluge de
roquette de violence dans une
multiplication ignoble d'actes de
barbarie des femmes des hommes des
personnes âgées des jeunes et des
enfants parfois même des bébés ont été
pris pour cible et comme toutes les
démocraties nous sommes au côté d'Israël
dans ces moments
terribles vous m'interrogez sur le rôle
de certains États dans cette
action d'abord avec l'ensemble de la
communauté
internationale nous appelons tous les a
condamné ces actes terroristes aucun
gouvernement ne peut rester insensible
face à ces
images s'agissant de l'Iran en
particulier le président de la
République a eu l'occasion de s'exprimer
hier nous n'avons pas de preuve formelle
de l'implication de l'Iran nous
consolidons nos analyses avec nos
partenaires ce qui est clair c'est le
caractère inacceptable des images de
triomphalisme ou de certains propos des
aut aorité iranienne il n'y a aucune
ambigué possible je condamne comme vous
avec la plus grande fermeté les pays qui
se sont félicités de cette attaque
terroriste
monstrueuse face à la gravité de la
situation nous agissons et nous agirons
en
responsabilité nous soutenons le droit
d'Israël à se défendre contre le
terrorisme sous l'gide du président de
la République la diplomatie est à
l'œuvre pour éviter l'embrasement et
calade dans la région nous sommes en
contact étroit avec nos partenaires pour
que la communauté internationale fasse
la lumière sur ces événements et le rôle
des uns et des autres nous rappelons que
les civils doivent être protégés et le
droit international
respecter nous soutenons toujours une
solution politique au conflit
israélo-palestinien notre position n'a
pas changé nous agissons également avec
nos partenaires européens la
coordination entre les États-membres
doit être entière et hier s'est tenue
une réunion informelle des 27 ministres
des Affaires étrangères de l'Union
européenne monsieur le Président
Marseille nous sommes au côté du peuple
israélien et avec nos partenaires nous
travaillons à identifier toutes les
responsabilités dans cette attaque
inacceptable je vous
remercie la parole